according to this gossip column my
nemesis miles
is dating lisa loeb the lisa loeb
songbird sex in glasses meanwhile
i have had zero bangs since moving to
this
garbage pile of a town that's not gonna
work for me so
new plan break up miles and lisa loeb
what the hell is going on here
it's parent-teacher day
well welcome to ap bio
[Music]
you can't talk to our kids about banging
i want to see a syllabus please
i want to see zero bangs okay listen
listen listen listen i don't know what
your kids
told you about me but i went to harvard
which means i know how to get
into harvard as well as the other ivy's
because they're all a little worse than
harvard
so keep your hands up if you don't want
your kids to go to harvard or one of the
lesser ivies now i believe all of your
remaining questions can be boiled down
to one simple answer
all of your kids know exactly what they
need to do to get an
a in my class right guys
and i'm happy to report that so far all
of your kids the fruit
of your loins are getting a's
so have a great rest of your day guys
excuse me
are we getting individual feedback yes
you uh honestly want to know what i
think about marcus
yes yeah he's just got a real turd of a
personality yeah but you two seem like a
couple of wet blankets as well
here's why heather's cool there's
something dangerous lurking inside of
her something edgy i think you need to
foster that
yeah guys get me my own pressure cooker
i want to make brisket and i want to
make it quick you're not old enough to
get a pressure cooker but i'm old enough
for an hpv vaccine
zarika has no sense of humor zero does
she laugh at anything zarika
refuses to have fun think i want to be
spending five hours every saturday at
the academic decathlon no
no no i'd rather be poolside buns up
sipping a malibu
it seems like why don't you ought to
give up the perm but what about when we
get separated at church or six flags
we always look for the curl
uh wow hold hands get a leash i don't
care go away
hi mrs um uh no i'm
i'm not um uh married i'm trash at
colin's mom oh
oh colin's mom hi sorry well i can
definitely see where he gets his um
his his book bag you got that for him
right i mean it's
it's a nice book bag you've got great
taste thank you well you know
kind of a book bag clothes connoisseur
and i mean i certainly didn't just
buy the first one i saw
you